- Good job.
Let's go ahead and keep moving.
We're gonna lunge
to the side for one.
(laughs loudly)
One, squeeze your abs.
- A cackle a day keeps
the cankles away.
(audience laughs)
- Sup Paul?
- Nothing much, Daniel.
- I do 30 of these a day,
it's great for the abs.
- Yeah, I don't believe in
doing abdominal exercises.
(bones crunch)
(audience gasps)
- I don't know
weightlifting, is that bad?
(audience laughs)
- Now, can somebody
tell me why women have
to make everything
so much harder?
Just another CrossFit
girl spending
Valentine's Day
with her barbell.
(audience laughs)
(bone cracks)
(audience gasps)
Now do chin-ups in
your oven mitts.
- Hi, my name is Vicky.
(laughter)
And I have breast cancer.
- Breast cancer is never funny.
- Yay, anybody else wanna share?
Yes?
- My name is Daniel.
(laughs loudly)
And my hair is thinning.
(laughs uncomfortably)
And I'm really allergic to cats.
(audience laughs)
And I'm dead inside.
Very good, very good.
(audience laughs)
Bunch of disease-riddled snobs.
I'm more of a laughter
Pilates guy anyway.
(rock guitar chord)
- Well howdy,
Prancercising princess.
- Howdy Daniel,
nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
I appreciate you coming.
My season starts in
three days and I need
to get in tip-top shape.
- Well, Prancercise
is the answer.
I'm telling you, Daniel,
there's nothing like it.
- I only have three days,
so I think I'm gonna
need larger weights.
Is Prancercising based
on your love for horses?
- What's not the love?
Strength, endurance,
and vegetarians.
(audience laughter)
- What's the best music
to Prancercise to?
- I love Motown.
Do the Prancercise walk first,
from side to side.
Let's go.
(upbeat music playing)
- I'm ready to pick up the pace.
- Alright.
The next mode is the trot.
(audience laughs)
- Don't sneak up on
someone Prancercising.
- The trot is
similar to the walk.
- Guys, we want you
to be Prancercising.
Guys, if you don't Prancercise,
you're prancer-fired.
(audience laughs)
(upbeat music continues)
- Thank you.
My body feels incredible
Prancercise lady.
- Remember, Daniel,
keep on prancin'!
(audience laughs)
Keep prancin'!
Keep on prancin'!